Iraqi troops led by us-led coalition
forces are pushing deeper into Mosul and
their offensive to drive out Isis from
Iraq second-largest city
soldiers from Iraq's emergency response
division are reportedly close to
storming the city's old quarter
observers say this could lead to an Isis
counter-offensive Iraqi forces pushed
Isis from eastern Mosul in January a
rocky state TV says about half of
Western Mosul has been taken the Iraqi
push to retake Mosul comes as some Isis
fighters are having second thoughts
about what they're fighting for
Holly Williams has that part of the
story this so-called Islamic state is
crumbling Iraqi forces are now on the
edge of Mosul's historic old town one of
the extremists last strongholds Isis
fighters are being killed and rounded up
as prisoners but even as they lose on
the battlefield they're still waging an
online propaganda war painting
themselves as a band of holy warriors
this Isis defector who we met in Turkey
shows just how powerful that propaganda
can be he told us he served in the
military in Jordan and then joined Isis
in late 2014
believing they've created a just Islamic
state but said he quickly realized he'd
made a mistake got the Fuhrer they kill
anyone who argues with them he was
surprised to discover their brutality
yet joined the extremists even after
he'd watched some of their vicious
execution videos including the
beheadings of two American journalists
why would you still join when you had
seen them committing atrocities like
that my own CIA they said they were CIA
agents not journalists he told us and
they slipped a verse from the Quran unto
the video to justify the killings
no Muslim could have checked or say this
is wrong Judith kathira 3 there were
many people who came to Isis like me he
said tens of thousands if they've known
the truth
they wouldn't have joined other for CBS
this morning Saturday Holly Williams
northern Iraq